اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم
160 الخ
بر
تسريبات الفانتاجون تخلط اوراق حلفاء
واشنطن اوكرانيا تشكك وموسكو تعتبرها حمله
حمله تضليل امريكيه
المدعي العام الذي اتهم ترامب يش
نه عبر القضاء
وسط تصاعد التوترات مع تايوان الرئيس
الصيني يدعو الجيش لتعزيز التدريب من اجل
قتال فعلي
وتتابعون معنا الليله ايضا
الامير هاري مدعون لحضور حفل تتويج والده
لكن بلا زوجته ونصف الامريكيين لا يرحبون
باقامته في الولايات المتحده
[موسيقى]
ككره ثلج تتدحرج قضيه تسريبات وثائق
الفانتاجون السريه ويوما بعد يوم يا طاهر
تمتد عاصفه الانتقادات لما شملته من وثائق
تخص دولا مثل اوكرانيا وروسيا والصين
وكوريا الجنوبيه وايران وتركيا وايضا كندا
تركز الوثائق والصور راويه التي سربت على
منصات تويتر وتليجرام واضافه الى غير ذلك
من المواقع في الايام الاخيره بشكل اساسي
على موضوعات متعلقه بالنزاع في اوكرانيا
الا انها تشمل ايضا موضوعات اخرى تتعلق
بحلفاء وخصوم للولايات المتحده صرع لتدارك
الموقف لكن بلا جدوى حتى الان واكد انه
يعمل على تحديد ما اذا كانت الوثائق اصليه
ومعتبرا ان عمليه التسريب تشكل خطرا جسيما
جدا على الامن القومي للولايات المتحده
اعلنت منصه التواصل الاجتماعي ديسكورد
انها تتعاون مع تحقيق سلطات الامريكيه حول
تسريب الوثائق السريه هذا وذكر تقرير صحفي
في وقت سابق ان الوثائق الامريكيه
العسكريه والاستخباراتيه شديده السريه تم
تسريبها عبر المنصه لاول مره في شهر يناير
اي قبل اشهر من الكشف عنها علنا لاول مره
طاهر الاراء والتحليلات تتضارب فيما يتعلق
بوثائق البنتاجون المسربه وخاصه في الدول
التي ورد ذكرها في هذه الوثائق ومن بين
هذه الدول اوكرانيا التي قال وزير دفاعها
اوليكس ان التسريبات الاخيره فيها مزيج من
الصدق والكذب دون ان يعطي تفاصيل اكثر
اضاف الوزير ان اكبر من استفاد من هذه
التسريبات تسريبات وثائق البنتاجون كانت
روسيا والدول الحليفه لها على حد قول وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني روسيا من جهه اعتبرت ان
الوثائق الامريكيه السريه المسربه بشان
النزاع في اوكرانيا قد تكون جزءا من حمله
تضليل امريكيه تهدف لخداع روسيا وسال
اعلام روسيه نقلت عن نائب وزير الخارجيه
سيرجرياوف قوله ان انهما من موقف في هذه
المرحله لروسيا معبرا عن اعتقاده بان
الوثائق ربما تكون مزيفه ودعايه متعمده
وفق تعبير
واعتبر نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسيه ان
الولايات المتحده جزء اساسي من الصراع في
اوكرانيا وانها قد تفعل ما بوسعها لخداع
روسيا بدوره قال المتحدث باسم الكريم
ان روسيا لا تعرف في هذه المرحله مدى صحه
الوثائق الا انه اشار الى ان روسيا اثبتت
وجود مدربين ومقاتلين من دول الناتو في
اوكرانيا حتى قبل تسريب الوثائق الامريكيه
طبعا نذكر بان بعض الوثائق شككت بفرص نجاح
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد المقرر على موسكو
او على بعض المناطق لهذا اعتبرت موسكو انه
مجرد تضليل لكن هناك سيناريوهات وضعت
لنهايه هذه الحرب نتعرف عليها معك بالفعل
الراويه وثيقه جديده من وثائق البانتاجون
المسربه حصلت عليها صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
وتتحدث عن اربعه سيناريوهات غير متوقعه
للحرب بين روسيا واوكرانيا اضافه الى
تاثيرها على مجريات المعارك وكالات
الاستخبارات وضعت هذه الافتراضات لمساعده
العسكريين او السياسيين على حد سواء على
التفكير في النتائج المحتمله اثناء
تقييمهم لخياراتهم تاريخ الوثيقه يعود الى
الرابع والعشرين من فبراير ويحمل علامه
سنه واحده مما يدل على ان التحليل جرى بعد
عام من بدايه الحرب في اوكرانيا
السيناريوهات الافتراضيه للحرب في
اوكرانيا تشمل مقتل الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين ومقتل الرئيس الاوكراني
تغيير القياده في الجيش الروسي واخيرا
حدود ضربات اوكرانيا على
الوثيقه بحثت ما يمكن ان يحدث اذا ضربت
اوكرانيا والتصعيد الذي قد يليه خاصه وان
حدثت او خاصه ان حدثت احتجاجات شعبيه
تطالب الرئيس الروسي بالرد الرد الروسي
بحسب الوثيقه قد يكون من خلال اطلاق تعبئه
عسكريه جديده واسعه النطاق والنظر في
استخدام الاسلحه النوويه التكتيكيه او
ربما قد يدفع الرئيس الروسي للتفاوض
نعم ربما هذا لدرجه معينه امر صحيح ولكن
من الملفت ان يعني معظم الاوراق والوثائق
المصنفه شديده السريه موجوده يعني بصيغه
ورقيه وليس بصيغه الكترونيه وعدت نسخها
محدود جدا في مثل هذه الحالات وربما يقدر
بنسختين او ثلاثه بمعنى انها معروفه فقط
لقيادات السياسيه وعسكريه عليا في اي بلد
كان وبالتالي يعني وجود مثل هذه التسريبات
امر يثير بعض الشكوك فيما صحتها ثانيا
طبعا هناك معلومات قديمه نوعا ما وليس لها
اي اهميه الان في الوقت الحاضر لا سيما
يخص ذلك مواعيد
الهجوم المضاده الذي ينوي الجيش الاوكراني
شمه ربما خلال
اسابيع قليله قادمه
كذلك عدد الالويه والوحدات العسكريه بوجه
عام والتي ربما سوف تشارك فيها يعني
المعلومات بهذا الشان مؤرخه منذ شهرين او
اكثر من ذلك وبالتالي الان لاهميه لها على
الاطلاق ولكن في اخبار كثيره عاجله قد تجب
ما قبلها بالاهميه عن مصادر تقول الان انه
بوتين وافق على اعتقال الصحفي الامريكي
المتجسس تقول ايضا ان هناك تاثير متزايد
لمسؤولين امريكيين في الكرملين لتعميق
المواجهه مع امريكا حتى جنوب افريقيا تقول
الان انه نواجه صعوبات في تنظيم قمه
المقبله بسبب مذكره اعتقال بوتين
انا لا اعتقد بان ليه كل هذه الفرضيات
اهميه يعني بالغه اولا لان الرئيس بوتين
طبعا اذا قرر المشاركه مثلا في قمه مجموعه
بوريكس فهو سيقوم بذلك بعض الحصول مثلا
على ضمانات بهذا الشان من السلطات جنوب
افريقيا وربما نفس شيئا ينطبق على مشاركته
في قمه العشرين
يعني مجموعه العشرين والتي من المقرر
عقدها في هذه السنه في الهند وهنا طبعا
لابد من الاشاره الى ان الهند هي دوله
تتمسك بحياد فيما يتعلق بالصراع الاوكراني
ولكن الاهم من كل هذا هو ان هذه الوثائق
المسربه لا تشكل اي اهميه بالنسبه للقوات
الروسيه التي تحارب في اوكرانيا لان
القياده العسكريه الروسيه كما يبدو متاكد
من ذلك
تعتمد فقط على مصادر موثوقه بها وهذه
المصادر تخص طبعا القنوات الامنيه الخاصه
بها نعم
سنتابع حديثنا معك وسعت الولايات المتحده
مشاهدينا قائمتها السوداء ضد روسيا بسبب
محاوله التحايل على العقوبات الغربيه وقال
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه في بيان ان
قرارات واشنطن الحاليه تنطبق على اكثر من
120 منظمه وفردا في اكثر من عشرين دوله
مؤكدا ان الاجراءات التقليديه الجديده قد
تم اتخاذها بحق من يدعمون العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه كما تطال اولئك الذين
يساعدون في التحايل على العقوبات الغربيه
المفروضه سابقا على روسيا
من جديد لا ينضم الينا يفغيني المحلل
السياسي من موسكو سيد يفقيني بالعوده الى
الوثائق الامريكيه المسربه هناك وثيقه
تتحدث عن قوات غربيه خاصه تعمل في
اوكرانيا اكثر من نصف عناصر تلك المجموعه
هم من البريطانيين طبعا وزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه قالت ان التسريبات غير دقيقه
ابدا الموقف الروسي من هذه النقطه تحديدا
خاصه في ظل هذا
اللغط حول مصداقيتها او ان كانت تعرضت
للتعديل هذه الوثائق
لو كانت مثل هذه المعلومات حول مشاركه
مثلا العناصر البريطانيه في المعارك التي
تدور في اوكرانيا لكن رد روسيا ربما اكثر
شده مما هو عليه الان لان روسيا في هذه
الحاله كان يمكن ان تعتبر مثل هذا الواقع
دليلا اخر على مشاركه مباشره من قبل دوله
عضو في الناتو وهي بريطانيا في هذه
العمليه العسكريه كما تسميها موسكو في
اوكرانيا وبالتالي ربما كان ذلك مبررا
للرد القوي جدا من قبل القوات الروسيه
شكرا جزيلا لكم
ميدانيا نفع الجيش الاوكراني مزاعم قوات
فاجنر الروسيه شبه العسكريه بانها استولت
على اكثر من 80% من مدينه بخبط ومشيرا الى
ان الجيش سيطر على اكثر بكثير من 20% في
شرق مدينه بخموت ومن جانبه اعلن المتحدث
باسم الجيش الشرقي الاوكراني ان قواته
تقدمت في الاستيلاء على مدينه باخمت بعد
شهور من القتال
[موسيقى]
ونتحول الان الى واشنطن حيث قالت قناه
فاكس نيوز ان الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب يقاضي محاميه السابق مايكل
كوهن بدعوى خرق العلاقه بين المحامي
وموكله والاسراء غير المشروع اضافه لاسباب
اخرى باكثر من 500 مليون دولار القناه
اضافت ان فريق ترامبل قانوني رفعت دعوه
المكونه من اكثر من 30 صفحه في المحكمه
الجزئيه للمنطقه الجنوبيه لفلوريدا اليوم
تشير الدعوه الى ان كوهين نشر اكاذيب حول
ترامب كان من المحتمل ان تكون محرجه او
ضاره وشارك بسوء نيه في انتهاك الشروط
التعاقديه لاتفاقيه السريه التي وقعها
كشرط للتوظيف مع مؤسسات
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مدعي عاما هاتنا الذي اتهم الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب يشن هجوما مضادا على القضاء
عبر القضاء عفوا ردا على اعضاء جمهوريين
في الكونجرس كلمه واحده في اللغه العربيه
تقلب الجمله راسا على عقب المدعي الفنبراج
الذي وجه الاتهام في الرابع من الشهر
الجاري رفع دعوى قضائيه ضد عضو جمهوري في
مجلس النواب لمنعه من التدخل في قضيته
وابطال اوامر الاستدعاء للمثول امام
براك تهم رئيس اللجنه القضائيه في مجلس
النواب جيم جوردن في الدعوه التي رفعها
الثلاثاء امام القضاء الفيدرالي في
نيويورك بشن هجوم غير مسبوق وغير دستوري
ضد تحقيقها تهدف هذه الدعوه الى منع
محاوله النائب وزملائه لاستدعاء المدعي
العام الى جلسه استماع امام الكونجرس كتب
المدعي العام في شكواه ان الكونغرس لا
يملك اي سلطه للاشراف على الملاحقات
الجنائيه لولايه امريكيه متهما
حمله صريحه لترهيبه وعرقلت التحقيقات ذكر
ايضا بان قرار توجيه الاتهام للرئيس
السابق ترامب اتخذته هيئه محلفين كبرى وهي
لجنه من المواطنين كانت اللجنه القضائيه
في مجلس النواب اصدرت مذكره استدعاء تطلب
شهاده
وهو كان نائبا لمدعي عاما هاتا واشرف على
تحقيق ترامب قبل ان يختلف مع براج حول
اتجاه التحقيق وقبل استقالته طبعا العام
الماضي من جانبه قال النائب جيم جوردن عبر
تويتر ان الادعاء وجه اتهاما لرئيس لم
يرتكب اي جريمه قبل المطالبه بمنع رقابه
الكونجرس مدعي عاما هاتا رد ايضا بتغريده
قال فيها ان الاعضاء الجمهوريين في
الكونجرس يقومون بخدعه سياسيه مطالبا بعدم
الانخداع بادعاءات الجمهوريين على حد قبح
مراسل العربيه اهلا بك معنا الليله بيار
يعني هناك مراجعه واسعه تحدث الان في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه حول الجهات
التي يمكنها تسريب هكذا معلومات والوصول
اليها وعدم الوقوع في هذا الخطا
بالمستقبل ماذا في تفاصيلها
نتحدث عن الوثائق طبعا ما حدث هو انه
ليس هناك حتى الان متهم تقول الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ان هذا الشخص هو الشخص
الذي قام بعمليه تسريب الوثائق ولكن
الانظار تتجه اكثر من اي وقت اخر الى
شخصيات تعمل
الى جانب قاده في الفندقون او وزير الدفاع
او شخصيه كبيره في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه قبل قليل
كان هناك بعض الملاحظات حول هل هناك
بالفعل تغيير في اداره البريد وتسليم
الوثائق في الفندقون او في الاماكن الاخرى
مسؤول كبير في الفيداجون الامريكي قال
للعربيه الى ان بالفعل وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه تقوم بعمليه اعاده نظر في عمليه
توزيع البريد والمعلومات للتاكد اولا من
ان هذه العمليه اي عمليه التسيب تحدث مره
اخرى ثانيا من الضروري ان يصلوا الى الشخص
الذي قام بعمليه التسريب هذا عظيم جدا هذه
قضيه ستتفاعل وسنتابعها معك اولا باول ومع
بقيه مراسلينا ولكن نستفيد من الوقت
المتبقي لنتحدث عن
موضوعي اللي كنت عم بشير اليه قبل قليل في
العرض السابق الان يبدو انه الموضوع يعني
استشرس قضائيا اكثر واكثر بعد رفع دعوه
ايضا من قبل الجهاز القضائي من قبل المدعي
العام شخصيا ضد عضو جمهوري اي مسلك واي
اتجاه
تتخذه هذه القضيه وكيف ستؤثر على القضيه
الاصليه قضيه
طاهر انت ذكرت الكثير من المعلومات حول
هذه العلاقه السيئه بين ابراج وجوردن
جوردن هو عضو مجلس النواب الامريكي ما
يريده المدعي العام في منحه هو ان يمنع
جوردن من ان يستجوب احد الاشخاص الذين
عملوا سابقا مع براج ثانيا يريد ان يمنعه
ايضا من ان يطلب شخصيات اخرى عملت على ملف
ترامب وبالتالي يعتبر المدعي العام في
منهدن ان هناك تدخل من اطراف خارجيه في
قضيه ترامب وانه هذا تدخل من قبل الكونجرس
في عمل القضاء الامريكي
شكرا جزيلا شكرا جزيلا العربيه من واشنطن
تحياتي اليك
[تصفيق]
في العربيه 360 ايضا
وفد ايراني يصل الى الرياض لبحث اعاده فتح
السفاره والقنصليه وطهران تسعى لتنشيط
بعثاتها قبل موسم الحج المقبل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد بحث وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان خلال اتصال
هاتفي مع المبعوث الاممي الى سوريا
والجهود الامميه في هذا الصبر وذكرت وكاله
الانباء السعوديه انا الوزير اكد حرصه
المملكه على بذل كافه الجهود للتوصل الى
حل سياسي مشددا على ضروره ان يحافظ الحل
على وحده سوريا وامنها واستقرارها
وانتماءها العربي وان يحقق الخير والنماء
لشعبها الشقيقه
اعلن المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الايرانيه ناصر كنعاني عن اصول وفد ايراني
الى السعوديه لاتخاذ الترتيبات اللازمه
لفتح سفاره ايران في الرياض وقنصلياتها في
جده كنعاني اوضح ايضا في تصريحات نشرتها
وسائل اعلاميه ان الوفد سيبحث في السعوديه
استئناف نشاط الممثلين الايرانيه الدائمه
في منظمه التعاون الاسلاميه مشيرا الى ان
طهران تسعى لفتح بعثاتها في السعوديه
واستئناف نشاطها قبل موسم الحج هذا هو
سيغادر الوفد الفني السعودي الذي وصل الى
ايران يوم السبت الماضي سيغادر متوجها الى
مشهد غدا لبحث اعاده فتح القنصليه
حاله من التفاؤل تعم الشارع اليمنيه مع
الحديث عن التوصل لخطوط عريضه للسلام مع
المباحثات الجاريه وتبقى فتح الطرقات
وعوده النازحين الى مناطقهم وتوحيد صرف
العمله المحليه هي ابرز اهتمامات اليمنيين
مع المخاوف المتكرره بعدم التزام الحوثيين
بالنتائج
بامال عريضه يترقب اليمنيون كل فرصه
للسلام وعوده الحياه لما كانت عليه قبل
الحرب
ثمان سنوات وتزيد من النزوح والتشرد وقطع
الطرقات وغياب الخدمات تقود الى تساؤل
واحد متى تضع الحرب اوزارها وفي مارب التي
تستوعب اكثر من 60% من اجمالي نازحين في
اليمن يتوق النازحون فيها العوده الى
ديارهم بعد سنوات من المعاناه المواطن
البسيط يتمنى الامن والامان والاستقرار
فقط لا غير وينعم بحياه هادئه ليقوم
باعمال اليوميه اما من ناحيه انه الحرب
تبقى واليمن يبقى على هذا الوضع والله
حياه كئيبه جدا
يحاول صادق الذي جاء من محافظه اب طلبا
للرزق ارسال ما جمعه من مال لاسرته لكن
فارقه صرف العمله بين مناطق سيطره الحكومه
الشرعيه والحوثيين يثقل كاهله يعني الان
يشتري بمئه الف يحولاته يعني باطل يعني
الناس شاقين الان على العمله
مع حاله التفاؤل في الشارع اليمني لانهاء
الحرب تبقى المخاوف عند البعض قائمه
بالنسبه للسلام كل اليمني يطمحونه الى
السلام لكن نحن مجربين مع الحوثي مسبقا
انه لم يفض الوعود حقه يعني
لم يفتحها ولم ينفذ من الوعود التي وعدتها
شيئا لكن عندنا امل ان شاء الله سبحانه
وتعالى اذا اذا اجدوا اليمنيين وخلصت
النوايا سيتم السلام ان شاء الله
يترقب اليمنيون اعلان نتائج المباحثات
والخروج من دوامه الحرب والصراع وعوده
اللحمه المجتمعيه امال كبيره عند اليمنيين
ان تتوقف الحرب ويعم السلام وتفتح الطرقات
بين المدن والمخاوف واحده وهي عدم التزام
الحوثيين بنتائج المباحثات محمود الحميدي
لقناه العربيه مارب
[موسيقى]
اكد رئيس مجلس السياده الانتقالي السوداني
عبد الفتاح البرهان التزام المؤسسه
العسكريه باكمال عمليه التوافق السياسي
والوطني وتحقيق الاستقرار للسودان وشدد
البرهان خلال لقائه بمبعوثه الاتحاد
الافريقي للقرن للقرن الافريقي حرصه على
حل الاشكالات العالقه من خلال التفاوض
والانفتاح على جميع المبادرات في هذا
الشان
[موسيقى]
دعا الرئيس الصيني القوات المسلحه الى
تعزيز التدريب العسكري من اجل قتال فعلي
واكد الرئيس الصيني ان بلاده ستدافع بحزم
عن سلامتها الاقليميه والحدود البحريه
وستسعى جاهده لتحقيق الاستقرار في المنطقه
واشار الى ان الصين ستعمل على ضمان
الاستجابه للتحديات المعقده وفي الوقت
المناسب
وفي احدث اجراء تايوان خفضت تكيين مده
الحظر الجويه الذي تفرضه على اجواء
الجزيره الى مده قصيره جدا حيث من المتوقع
ان يؤدي مثل هذا الاجراء الى شبه شلل
لحركه الطيران جنوب وشرق اسيا
27 دقيقه المده المسموح بها لتعبره هذه
الاجواء شمال تايوان ذهابا وايابا قرار
فرضته السلطات الصينيه في احدث اجراء فيما
يتعلق بالجزيره التي تريد بيكين ضمها
وزاره النقل التايوانيه قالت ان بكين
ستخفض مده حظر الطيران التي ستفرضها فوق
شمال تايوان من سبع ساعات الى 27 دقيقه
فقط في الخطه الاوليه ولمده ثلاثه ايام
ابتداء من السادسه عشر من ابريل وحتى
الثامنه عشر من الشهر نفسه حيث سيؤثر
الامر على الستين الى 70% من الرحلات بين
الشمال شرق اسيا وجنوب شرق اسيا وزاره
الدفاع التايوانيه قالت ان الحظر مفرود من
جانب الصين وليست تايوان وان منطقه حظر
الطيران تقع في حدود منطقه التعريف الدفاع
الجوي للتايوان رجحت الوزاره ان حظر
الطيران يتعلق بشكل اساسي بنشاطات فضائيه
صينيه او اطلاق قمر اصطناعي
بكين كانت اجرت خلال الايام القليله
الماضيه منورات عسكريه ودفعت ببعض
طائراتها وقطاعها البحريه العسكريه الى ما
بعد الخط الذي يفصل مضيقه تايوان منصفه
بين البلدين ويشكل خط المواجهه بينهما في
سيناريو لفرض حصار على الجزيره وحظر جوي
وبحري كان التقارير استخباراتيه توقعت ان
تلجا الصين الى الحصار بدلا من الغزو
المباشر حصار يبدو ان بكين بداته ب 27
دقيقه في خطتها الاوليه كما سمتها
[موسيقى]
كشف استطلاع جديد للراي ان اكثر من نصف
الامريكيين يعتقدون ان تاشيره الاقامه
الخاصه بالامير هاري يجب ان تتم مراجعتها
من قبل وزاره الامن الداخلي في ضوء
اعترافه بطاعات المخدرات في مذكراته على
الرغم من ان عددا مشابها يقول انه كان
محقا في تضمينها
بين دفتي كتابه يرمي بحجاره تاره يفتخر
بقتله خمسه وعشرين عنصرا من طالبان ومره
اخرى يعترف عالجت غياب امي بالكوكايين
اعترافات يرويها الامير هاري في الكتاب
القنبله المسمى
حروف ورطت هاري وادخلته في دوامه الاوضاع
القانونيه في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
قد تصل به للترحيل من اراضيها
معضله قانونيه اقحم بها نفسه هاري باقراره
انه تناول جرعه من المخدرات ليذهب بها
معتركه احزانه على فقدان والدته الاميره
ديانا
لكن الامير هاري قد يفقد وضعه كمهاجر حيث
كشف استطلاع راي نشرته نيوزويك الامريكيه
ان 54% من عينه بلغت
شخص يعتقدون ان تاشيره اقامته يجب
مراجعتها من قبل وزاره الامن الداخلي بسبب
اعترافته الصادمه وفي سؤال اخر قالت نسبه
مماثله انهم شعروا ان الاميره كان على حق
في الافصاح عن تاريخه مع تعاطي المخدرات
في مذكراته طعن قانوني يواجهه هاري بعد
اقامه حظي بها لثلاث سنوات لن يخرجه من
امريكا فحسب وانما قد يضع له قيودا في
السفر منها واليها وربما المنع من التقدم
بطلب للحصول على الجنسيه
ينضم الينا من لندن عدد درويش مراسل معتمد
في مجلس العموم البريطانيه اهلا بك معنا
استاذ عادل مره جديد على شاشه العربيه هل
تتدخل بريطانيا على اي مستوى في الوضع
القانوني للامير هاري في داخل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بموضوع الاقامه مثلا
مساله علاقه بريطانيا بامريكا مساله حساسه
لعده نواحف لا تنسى ان الحرب الاستقلال
الامريكيه الامريكيه كانت بريطانيا اصلا
بريطانيا القوه الاستعماريه وحتى لو لاحظت
في الافلام
دائما يطلع الشخصيه الشرير الرجل
الانجليزي فبريطانيا عاده تتدخل في هذه
المثال النقطه الثانيه ان الامير هاري
بيصير قلق هنا لان الشعبيات وهنا في الراي
العام البريطاني ينخفض كثيرا وبالتالي
اعتقد الحكومه البريطانيه ستفكر مش مرتين
هتفكر 10 مرات قبل التدخل في هذا الشهر
طيب سيد عادل يعني الامير هاري سيشارك في
حفل تتويج الملك تشارلز لكن من دون زوجته
ماجن بكل مره يشارك الملك بهكذا يعني
الامير هاري فعليا بهكذا مناسبه يقال انه
او يسال هل ستكون مقدمه لمصالحه عائليه
الجواب يكون بالعكس يكون هناك قنبله جديده
مذكرات او حتى يعني تفاصيل اكثر حول خلافه
مع اخيه وما الى ذلك ماذا سيحصل
ماذا سيحصل هنا هي مساله طبعا
تتعلق بالشرح
البروتوكولا الدستوري التقليدي
وبالشكل الشعبي بشكل عائلي يعني على عده
مستويات كما قلت على المستوى الشعبي
الامير هاري للاسف بسبب زوجته الامريكيه
المتكلميه شعبيه منخفضه على مستوى العائله
لا تنسي ان اجدت في الملك تشارلز واب في
النهايه وكان يتمنى ان يشهد او كل اولاده
واحفاده معه لكن قرار ميجن بالبقاء بعيدا
واذا بالمناسبه هتكون عيد ميلاد ابنها
كمان في هذا الوقت ربما يعني يكون قرار
حكيم بعض الشيء
مساله اسماء التتويك كل العائله الملكه
بما فيهم الامير يجب ان ينزل على البتاعه
ويقبل يد الملك او الخاتم في
لتقديم مولود الطاعه والولاء لان هذا جزء
من التقاليد
البروتوكوليه لا اعتقد ان هذه مهما بلغت
به الحماقه
سيفسد هذه المناسبه او يدلي
بتصريع غير حكيم لان هذا يفقدهم من
الشعبيه ما تنسيش ان كل اللي بيعملوا هذا
ان هو بيروج لكتابه وبيروج لشعبيته فكونوا
ساحضر هذا على التتويك اذا امر ايجابي
طبعا لهذا الخبر طلع اليوم فقط ما كانش حد
متوقع بيان قصر باكنام عن حضور الامير
هاري تتويج والده الملك تشارلز في لندن
بدون رفقه الاستاذ عادل درويش مراسل معتمد
معتمد في مجلس العموم البريطاني من لندن
شكرا جزيلا لك
وفي العربيه 360 ايضا يوثق زيارته
لايرلندا الشماليه بصوره سيلفي تفاصيلها
بعد التفاصيل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قال رئيس الفرنسي
مانيويل ماكرون في معرض اجابته على سؤال
حول استقلال القرار الفرنسي فيما يخص
مساله تايوان ان بلاده حليفه للولايات
المتحده وليست تابعه لها
والعمل على ايجاد حل سلمي لهذه المساله
وهذا هو الموقف الاوروبي وهذا موقف كان
دائما متناغما مع دور الحليف وهنا اصر على
دوري الاستقلاليه الاستراتيجيه ان تكون
حليفا ليس معناه ان تكون تابعا ليس لاننا
حلفاء ولاننا نعمل معا انه ليس لدينا الحق
في ان نفكر بانفسنا
لم تكن زياره الرئيس الفرنسي مانيوال
ماكرون لهولندا سهله بل شهدت الكثير من
الاحتجاجات خلال يومي الزياره فيما قابل
يا طاهر مكروه عدد من المحتجين منهم من
عبر عن غضبه بطريقته الخاصه
الرئيس الفرنسي لم يهنا لحظه
زياره رسميه الى هولندا حملت فوضى
ومشاحنات في يومها الاول
هتاف ولا فتات بعنوان رئيس العنف والنفاق
خلال خطابه حول مستقبل اوروبا في لاهاي
في اليوم التالي محتجون اعترضوا طريق
ماكرون فقبضت الشرطه على عدد منهم ياتي
هذا على خلفيه مظاهرات فرنسا الغاضبه ضد
قانون رفع سن التقاعد من 62 الى 64 عاما
تفرض الاضرابات وضعا اقتصاديا صعبا على
العمال المضربين في فرنسا في ايام الاضراب
تخصم من الراتب لكن النقابات فتحت صندوقا
للتبرعات هذا الصندوق يدعم حركه الاضراب
وتغطى بفضله اجور الموظفين المضربين عن
العمل
اقتصادي كبير تشكله الاضرابات على العمال
المضربين في فرنسا كل يوم اضراب يحسب
اجازه غير مدفوعه الاجر وبعض الاضرابات قد
تمتد لاسابيع مثل ما هو الحال في قطاع
الطاقه او النظافه النقابات العماليه وجدت
الحله من خلال صندوق للتبرعات تلقى ارقاما
خياليه خلال اقل من ثلاثه اشهر
التبرعات يتم جمع اغلبها خلال التظاهرات
كليمو وجمال موظفان مضربان عن العمل تطوعا
في فريق يجمع التبرعات من متظاهرين دخلهم
محدود اصلا لكن لحظه وضع قطعه نقديه في
الصندوق هي الفوز الكبير
[موسيقى]
العربيه باريس
توصل هيئه الهلال الاحمر السعودي تقديم
الخدمات الانسانيه والرعايه المجتمعيه
خلال شهر رمضان المبارك وتشارك الهيئه في
عده مجالات منها التطوع الاسعافي
والانساني بالاضافه الى التوعيه والتثقيف
بعدد متطوعين يصل لاكثر من 25 الف متطوع
ومتطوعه حيث تم مباشره الالاف من البلاغات
اليوميه التي تصل من حالات مرضيه
[موسيقى]
ورئيس وزراء بولندا نسعى الانتاج قضاء
اليورانيوم المنظف لدبابات الامريكيه ولكن
نتابع رمضانيا من مكه المكرمه مع مراسل
العربيه اسامه القاسم راويه راويه القاسم
حدثنا عن الهلال الاحمر السعودي عن اعداد
النقاط تواجدها كيف يقومون بمساعده
المعتمرين والحالات الصعبه التي يعني
بعالجوها
اهلا وسهلا راويه اهلا طاهر تحيه طيبه
لكما ولجميع مشاهدي العربيه انقل لكم
الصوت والصور اليوم من احدى مراكز هيئه
الهلال الاحمر السعودي المتواجده في الحرم
المكي الشريف بالتحديد مركز الشبيكه طبعا
هنا في الحرم المكي اكثر من سبعه مراكز
متواجده الهلال الاحمر ليبشروا فيها تلك
الحالات التي تحصل على الزوار والمعتمرين
يتحدث عن ان اغلب الحالات المتواجده اليوم
في الحرم المكي هي عباره عن حالات اغمى او
حالات بسيطه لا تستدعي رعايه طبيه متكامله
يتم نقلها الى المستشفيات المتواجده في
الحرم المكي واخص بالتحديد مستشفى الحرم
ومستشفى اجياد الطوارئ نترككم الان في
صوره حول هذه الادوات المجهزه تجهيزا
كاملا لمباشره اي حاله طارئه تحصل هنا في
رحاب المسجد الحرام نتحدث اليوم عن اكثر
من 30 الف ساعه تراكميه تطوعيه لعدد كبير
جدا من المتطوعين قدر عددهم باكثر من 25
الف متطوع ومتطوع نتحدث ايضا عن اكثر من
75 سياره اسعاف اكثر ايضا من عشر عربات
جولف مجهزه حديثا نقل الحالات وايضا
لمباشره الحالات المتواجده في الحرم المكي
الشريف نتحدث ايضا عن ان هناك عدد من
الحالات ايضا تم مباشرتها اكثر من ثمانيه
عشر الف حاله بالعاصمه المقدسه عدد
الحالات المنقوله منها قرابه الخمسه الاف
و700 حاله طبعا اكثر البلاغات طلبا للفرقه
الاسعافيه هي عباره عن حالات مرضيه خفيفه
او حوادث مروريه نتحدث ايضا عن ان الهلال
الاحمر يملك 20 دراجه هوائيه مجهزه باحدث
المعدات لمباشره الحال لن تتحدث عن سبع
دراجات ناريه عن 17 مركزا داخليا بالعاصمه
المقدسه وسبعه مراكز في الحرم المكي واكثر
من 800 قوه بشريه متواجده في انحاء الحرم
المكي الشريف نتحدث ايضا عن 150 متطوع
يوميا في الحرم المكي الشريف وهناك ايضا
اربع عربات كوارث مجهزه لنقل الحالات
الطارئه اذا اليوم راويه طاهر نتحدث عن
هذه الجهود الكبيره للهلال الاحمر السعودي
اغلب الحالات التي ذكرها هي بعض الحالات
البسيطه كالاعياء الموجود على كبار السن
او حتى ذوي الامراض المزمنه كالضغط والسكر
يتم نقله مباشره الى المستشفيات المتواجده
هنا في الحرم المكي في حال ان الحاله كانت
تدعي وصولها الى مستشفى اخر او النقل جميع
مستشفيات مكه المكرمه اعلنت جاهزيتها
بالكامل بعدد اسره كبيره جدا بجميع الغرف
المتواجده في مستشفيات مكه المكرمه اكثر
من عشر مستشفيات وسبعه وثمانين مركز صحي
يستقبلون الحالات العاجله هنا في الحرم
المكي الشريف اتحدث اليوم ايضا كنا بحديث
مع مسؤولين الهلال الاحمر ان هذه الايام
ايضا بحكم زياده اعداد الزوار والمعتبرين
يشهدون حالات كثيره وطارئه متواجده هنا في
الحرم المكه شريف كما سبقت هناك سبعه
مراكز موزعه بحيث ان لا يكون هناك تداخل
او تزاحم بين الزوار والمعتمرين ويتم
حالات الحالات المباشره ومتابعتها بشكل
مستمر بالتاكيد ايضا السعوديه اعطت كل
الدعم المتواجد اليوم لتقديم الخدمات
الانسانيه والصحيه والعلاجيه لزوار
وقاصدين بيت الله الحرام لاجل ان يعيشوا
تجربه استثنائيه وان ينعموا باداء مناسكهم
اليوم في الحرم المكي بكل يسر وسهوله
وطمانينه شكرا جزيلا لك اسامه القاسم
مراسل العربيه من مكه المكرمه شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
تحقيق حديث لرويتورز ان ايران استغلت
كارثه الزلزال الذي وقع في سوريا في
فبراير لترسل اسلحه ومعدات عسكريه متنكره
في شكل مواد اغافيه لدعم النظام السوري
ودفاعات ايران ضد اسرائيل في سوريا
كشف تحقيق لرويترز ان رحلات الاغاثه
الانسانيه العاجله المتوجهه من ايران الى
سوريا بعد زلزال السادس من فبراير لم تكن
محمله بالمساعدات بل بمعدات عسكريه تسعه
مصادر سوريه وايرانيه واسرائيليه وغربيه
قالت لرويترز ان ايران استخدمت رحلات
لاغاثه الجويه لادخال اسلحه ومعدات عسكريه
الى حليفتها سوريا وتحديدا عبر مطارات حلب
ودمشق واللاذقيه بحسب المصادر لرويتيرز
الهدف كان دعم دفاعات ايران ضد اسرائيل في
سوريا وتعزيز الدفاعات السوريه التابعه
لنظام الاسد تضمنت الامدادات ومعدات
اتصالات متطوره وبطاريات الرادار وقطع
غيار مطلوبه لنظام الدفاع الجوي السوري
الذي قدمته ايران بحسب مصادر اقليميه
واستخباراتيه غربيه لرويتورز المبعوث
الايراني الى الامم المتح بدوره استخدام
بلاده لطائرات اغاثه انسانيه بعد وقوع
الزلازل لنقل معدات عسكريه الى سوريا في
المقابل رصدت اسرائيل تحركات كبيره لنقل
معدات عسكريه ايرانيه تحت ستار شاحنات
مساعدات الزلزال الى سوريا وتم نقلها على
شكل قطع متفرقه مسؤول تابع للدفاع
الاسرائيلي قال ان المساعدات سلمت بشكل
اساسي الى مطار حلب شمالي سوريا وان
الشحنات كانت تنظم من قبل وحده تابعه
لفيلق القدس التابع للحرس الثوري
كان رده فعل وجهت اسرائيل ضربه لمدرج حلب
بعد ساعتين فقط من هبوط طائرات الشحن
الايرانيه المحمله بالاسلحه المتنكره على
شكل مواد غافيه بحسب مصدر اقليمي ومصدرين
استخباراتيين غربيين لرويترز رش خياط
العربيه
[موسيقى]
اذا مراسل العربيه يتحدث عن اجلاء الجيش
العراقي سكان منطقه بمحافظه صلاح الدين
بسبب الفيضانات الى صوره اليوم في العربيه
360 اذا كنت تبحث عن وظيفه شاغره وبراتب
مجزن وكبير
في وظيفه كقائد دبابه او حتى قناص حتما
ستجد عملا في روسيا فشوارع موسكو باتت
مليئه بصور اعلانات للتطوع والعمل في
الجيش الروسي حتى ان العمل يا طاهر لا
يتطلب سنوات خبره في الاعلان ايضا مطلوب
للعمل في القطاع الطبي خبي
ر تقدر
ما السبب ان الوظيفه هو القتال على
الجبهات
[موسيقى]
والان الى فيديو اليوم من العربيه 360
فخلال زيارته لايرلندا الشماليه حيث اصول
اجداده
ظهر الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن واظهر
براعته في
التقاطه
لازم نشوف الصوره
فعلا ولا لا ما شفناهاش بالتفصيل على كل
النكته بهذا القدر ولكن اخبار الساعه لا
تنقطع صهيب شراير يتابع فيها الان مساء
الخير
مساء النور راويه وطاهر كالعاده هو اجمالي
اهم اخبار اليوم في ساعتنا السريعه
الشامله والمتنوعه اخبار ساعه سنركز على
مساله تجديد اجراءات التجنيد في كل من
روسيا واوكرانيا ربما استعدادا لمعركه
كبيره في اوكرانيا اليك تفضل
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات